this video is sponsored by the book
summary service blinkist the first 100
people to use the link in the
description will receive one free week
of unlimited access and 25 off a full
membership
we feel as though we are in the driver's
seat of our mind driving according to
our conscious will but upon only a
little introspection we realize at least
in many cases we are merely following a
built-in navigation system that exceeds
our knowledge and understanding we
perceive but the display screen atop an
entire complex software run on an even
more complex hardware if we do not
attempt to familiarize ourselves with
this navigation system how it works
where it's trying to go and how to
override it when it sends us the wrong
direction we risk aimlessly traveling
the world ending up somewhere
uninteresting at best and disastrous at
worst
20th century swiss psychiatrist carl
jung is perhaps one of the greatest and
most capable minds that has ever
attempted to do this to explore itself
from the inside and conceptualize a
complete understanding of this sort of
internal navigation system from the top
down
[Music]
jung was born in 1875 in caswell
switzerland to a relatively impoverished
royal pastor paul young and a depressed
eccentric spirit-seeing mother emily
young
jung was a very introverted and isolated
child who spent much of his time alone
engaging in activities of make-believe
projection disassociation and analyzing
the adults in his life during early
childhood he strongly disliked and
underperformed in school to the point of
almost neurosis regularly fainting to
get out of it however as age and
maturity would have it and after his
father expressed stern concern over his
potential incompetence jung somewhat
dramatically shifted to engaging more
intensely in his education reading
actively on his own especially that of
philosophy and religious texts
following secondary school after
determining that he did not want to
follow the family's path of a religious
vocation jung would end up pursuing
medicine at the university of basel
after getting his completed medical
degree from the university of zurich in
1902 he would work at a psychiatric
hospital under the prominent and
well-connected psychiatrist eugene
bluhler
several years later he would leave the
hospital and begin his own private
practice
as jung became more successful and well
known in his field he would soon become
acquainted with the extremely popular
groundbreaking and controversial
psychologist of the time who still holds
this title today sigmund freud the two
would meet for the first time in 1907
upon which they would talk for around 13
hours straight
this would quickly develop into a strong
friendship and professional
association they traveled the world and
lectured together analyzed each other's
dreams and discussed various aspects of
their psychological studies and theories
however freud being of a much greater
professional stature at the time as well
as being substantially older than jung
created a dynamic in the friendship that
was much more like a father-son or
teacher-pupil relationship this would
unfortunately pose problems as jung's
career advanced and began to encroach on
freud's the two would soon find
themselves in disagreements over
fundamental aspects of each other's
theories
ultimately these disagreements jung's
tendency toward a somewhat mystical
consideration of the human mind as
opposed to freud's more scientific
reductionist approach the nature of
their father-son relationship and jung's
desire for professional independence all
caused the two to split their friendship
off in 1913.
following and as a consequence of this
breakup from around 1913 to 1918 jung
experienced a sort of mid-life
psychological breakdown
during this he spent much of his time
introspecting and writing about
psychological experiments he conducted
on himself exploring into the recesses
of his unconscious
this period of transition independence
and psychological turbulence would
ultimately concretize his views of the
mind and his career as an independent
theorist of psychology
[Music]
put simply the primary objective of
jung's career was to understand the
nature of the psyche and then develop
theories and methods to aid in the
integration of all its components so to
create a singular unified state of
wholeness
in this context the psyche here simply
refers to the complete personality of
the individual including feelings
thoughts and behaviors the combination
of the unconscious and conscious mind
the continuous striving toward
integrating the psyche through a process
of self-realization and becoming a
maximized authentic individual for jung
was the fundamental goal of life and
psychological understanding
man's task he wrote is to become
conscious of the contents that press
upward from the unconscious as far as we
can discern the sole purpose of human
existence is to kindle a light in the
darkness of mere being
for jung there is a constant interplay
between the unconscious and conscious
realms of the psyche which combine to
create our complete personality most of
this however develops and exists in the
unconscious realm beneath our immediate
awareness and control
thus a significant portion of who we
really are what we really like and are
capable of and the reasons we do the
things we do persist within a realm we
don't actively understand or have access
to
and so in order to come into a more
authentic and complete state of being
the individual must attempt to make this
portion of the psyche conscious by
tapping into it and integrating it into
the whole of their awareness
jung would call this process
individuation
in order to better understand this it is
important to understand jung's model of
the psyche which he divided starting
with the broader dimensions into
consciousness personal unconsciousness
and collective unconsciousness
breaking each of these three realms down
consciousness is as one would typically
think of it the realm of personal
awareness where one identifies
explicitly and knowingly with themselves
at the core of this is another structure
young identified the ego the ego sits at
the center of consciousness and provides
a sense of personal distinction creating
the story one tells themselves about
themselves in order to maintain
continuity in their identity the ego is
expressed in the conscious realm by what
jung called the persona which is the
outward efforts of appearance which the
individual actively displays to the
world
this persona however is often disjointed
from the individual's true self as it
displays the character that one thinks
or wants to be according to what the ego
deems is appropriate to a particular
society and role and not what is true to
who the individual actually is
in order to execute and maintain this
suitable appearance and self-esteem the
ego filters various components of
personal experience and selfhood either
into or away from the conscious
dimension what it filters away and
restricts it represses and sends down
into the unconscious realm
one of jung's most unique and profound
insights that differentiates him most
notably from other psychologists is how
from here he separated the unconscious
into two distinct structures the
personal unconscious and the collective
unconscious
the personal unconscious fit similarly
into the ideas already understood and
proposed by freud and others of the time
in which after the ego represses and
disregards undesirable aspects of
experience and selfhood these aspects
are stored and concealed here just
beneath normal awareness they still
however continue to actively affect and
interact back and forth with
consciousness
the collective unconscious however
differentiates from the personal
unconscious and other prior conceptions
of the psyche in that according to jung
it contains and facilitates universal
elements that are inherited through the
sum total of human history similar in
some sense to how biological evolution
works
man has developed consciousness slowly
and laboriously in a process that took
untold ages to reach the civilized state
and this evolution is far from complete
for large areas of the human mind are
still shrouded in darkness wrote jung
as a result of each generation of human
offspring essentially imitating the
behaviors of the previous generation to
at least some degree an unbroken chain
of psychological imitation is formed
going all the way back to the beginning
of human history
thus a sort of reservoir of
psychological predispositions structures
and memories that have been formed by
this chain is automatically inherited by
each human being
jung found this to be empirically
demonstrable in both his own
professional psychiatric practice
finding recurring similarities in the
unconscious of a vast number of his
patients as well as his historical and
mythological research in which he
noticed that similar motifs symbols and
themes that appeared in his patients
unconscious also were prevalent and
consistent across art myths and
literature within different cultures of
different times even though these
cultures often never even encountered
one another
in jung's view these shared motifs
symbols and themes were expressions of
the various psychic structures
consistent across humanity which he
called archetypes
these archetypes in jung's model of the
psyche essentially form the basis of the
individual's personality by predisposing
specific cognitive tendencies
within the combined unconscious jung
would refer to all the repressed denied
and unknown content which the ego does
not want to identify with as the shadow
lastly sort of nested within the shadow
is what young broke down into the animus
and anima which specifically referred to
the suppressed feminine qualities in a
male anima and the suppressed masculine
qualities in a female and a must
according to jung all the aforementioned
structures of the psyche work together
in active circulation to ultimately form
what lies at the center the self the
combined authentic totality of the
unconscious and conscious
the self is who the individual actually
is what they actually desire what they
actually like what they are actually
capable of and so on
simply put getting the ego and a high
degree of the persona as close to this
as possible is the goal of individuation
and ultimately a fulfilled life
whether it's through methods like
therapy
introspection personal development
toward authenticity or some combination
ultimately for young it is the task of
the individual to determine and strive
toward this
in all cases this sort of
self-realization requires an effort of
radical self-acceptance and radical
self-acceptance requires an effort of
radical self-honesty
in order to actively move deeper into
the psyche each opportunity one takes to
examine a personal feeling thought or
action they must attempt to do so by
accepting the complete and often
undesirable potentiality of what it
truly indicates about themselves that
they are not always who they think or
hope they are
each of these capitalized opportunities
personal or professional is like a small
step down the stairwell into the
unconscious
as one goes further down however as they
confront these deeper and darker
elements of their being hidden in the
basement they must in jungian terms work
to integrate their shadow the breadth of
their potential faults and wickedness as
opposed to rushing back up the stairs
and denial
one shadow does not disappear by looking
away from it in the same way one cannot
literally evade the light-casted shadow
of their body by outrunning it there is
no move or evasive tactic that separates
the individual from their psychological
shadow the danger rather is in the
attempt to do so the ignorance and
denial of it good does not become better
by being exaggerated but worse and a
small evil becomes a big one through
being disregarded and repressed
the shadow is very much a part of human
nature and it is only at night that no
shadows exist
wrote jung awareness of one's dark side
allows one to more appropriately manage
and recognize it when it sneaks up the
stairs uninvited one must know of a
problem to be able to fix it and it is
an act of healing to admit that one is
sick although self-acceptance and
authenticity is perhaps simple and
obvious enough sounding the act of
actually working towards radical
self-acceptance and individuation is of
course far from simple and obvious
in the absolute sense it is almost
certainly impossible in the above
average sense it is still perhaps life's
greatest and most difficult endeavor to
truly and honestly accept your downfalls
weaknesses potential evils and shameful
or unpopular interests and qualities to
admit what you see fear or hate in
others is and could be inside of you to
admit to yourself that you are not and
will never be completely who you think
and want to be that you are not as good
as you had hoped and to confront what
your mind has worked a lifetime to keep
from itself is a task that literally
shakes the very core of the psyche
however it is perhaps proportionally
essential for a fulfilled and complete
life
ultimately young's work provides
insights theories and methods to help
the individual move through this process
toward not only potentially gaining
access to fixing the bugs in their
navigation system but also in some sense
access to the controls where now they
can better input the destination
coordinates according to where they
actually can
and want to go
[Music]
this video was sponsored by blinkist
whether you're interested in learning
more about jung's theories sigmund
freud's or other individuals and
concepts in psychology there is
certainly no shortage of great
literature
so much so that it would likely take an
entire lifetime just to get through a
portion of it at an average reading pace
of course this problem in general can
make it hard to engage with the full
breadth and depth of any areas of
non-fiction literature that one is
interested in which sometimes can even
discourage one from reading much at all
however the book summary app blinkist
helps solve this problem by streamlining
the reading and learning process by
providing the overviews chapter
takeaways and essential information of
complete non-fiction books in just
around 15-minute summaries which can be
both read or listened to conveniently
and otherwise small pockets of down time
in only around 15 minutes you can learn
more about jung's ideas of archetypes
and the unconscious and man and his
symbols freud's key theories on the
nature of dreams and the interpretation
of dreams or a modern analysis on
personality types in the four tendencies
by gretchen rubin ultimately no matter
what your interests are with 27
categories of thousands of non-fiction
titles to choose from blinkist allows
you to explore vastly more topics and
books in a way that would otherwise take
massive amounts of extra time and even
better blinkist now also has complete
audio books of select titles as well as
podcast summaries from popular podcasts
so you can delve into complete books and
topics that you want to get the full
comprehensive scope of all in the same
place
the first 100 people to use the link in
the description will receive one free
week of unlimited access as well as 25
off of full membership the free
seven-day trial can be canceled at any
time within the trial period
and of course as always thank you so
much for watching in general and see you
next video
you